alhamdulillah one of the greatest
obligation which Allah has obligated
upon us after worshiping him alone
without associating anything as a
partner with him likewise fulfilling the
right of the messenger of Allah
S is to be kind to our parents to be
kind to our parents
Allah
mentioned the meaning of the verse Allah
said worship Allah and not associate
anything as a partner with him and be
kindful and be good to your parents
but Allah has command Us in his no book
to be good to our parents to have a good
relationship with them even if they are
disbelievers even if they are a
disbelievers rather even if they command
you to to associate partners with Allah
subhah wa taala you should still be good
to them and respectful to them yes you
don't not hear them and Obey them in
disobeying Allah waala but that should
not be justification for you to
disrespect them the meaning of the verse
Allah subhah wa tala mentioned we have
advised the insan the human
being to be good to his parents
concerning his mother she carried him
weakness upon weakness and likewise
Allah
mentioned even even they strive hard and
harder hard and harder to make you fall
in to disbel you should not listen to
them but yet be good to them Subhan
Allah Allah have mercy upon Him
mentioned this a site point but it's
very important he said if the to to
fight the non-believers because they are
disbelievers only that's the only reason
for us to fight against them then Allah
would have commanded the believer to
fight against his own parents who they
strive to make him fall into dis belief
but this the Clear Proof you don't not
fight the verses dealing with fighting
disbelievers in the Quran Sunnah not
because they're just disbelievers rather
if they were to war against the Muslims
or they prevent the Muslims to establish
their religion that's the wisdom behind
it not the go to the train innocent
people non Muslims and he said it's from
Jihad yes he's right he a Jihad in the
part of not in the
of so the sh here even there are dis
belever belies what about if the other
believers and what we hear from the
stories young Brothers young sisters
even old brothers disrespecting their
parents disrespecting their mothers
disrespecting their fathers when Allah
command us to be good to them to be nice
to them to be to to look after them to
treat them with respect so we have to
strive to Jihad against our own selves
in dealing with our parents yes
sometimes our parents they go to tell us
something which doesn't not go in line
with our desires or what we want but we
have to be good to them yes if they tell
you to disobey Allah you don't not hear
them and Obey them but as we have
mentioned based upon the quranic verses
likewise that should not be
justification for you to disrespect your
mother or your father please don't fure
you are a real man when you disrespect
your parents you're just a coward and
Allah will bring someone to
you and this that's what mention there
certain Disobedience Allah would not
punish the people here in this world he
will punish them in the here after or
forgive them except disrespecting the
parents Allah will punish you in this if
you don't not make Allah will humiliate
you in
this some people if they parents out for
money we start complaining a man came
to and he he said oh messenger of Allah
my father keep taking my money he said
you and your money belongs to your
father Yes the father should
not oppress his son or oppress his
daughter
so likewise Allah told us or this ntion
a man came
to he said oh messenger of Allah I want
to do Jihad fighting with the soul or
physical fight physical Jihad he said is
are your parents alive he said yes he
said go and do
Jihad with them meaning to strive in
pleas in your parents Subhan Allah and
what we have in the stories young
children going to Syria claiming they
want to fight for Isis
and may Allah preserve he says no these
people are with made by the by the the
the enemies of
Islam they're not fighting for the sake
of
just to get a side point before Isis
came about all the social media I mean
all the outlet outlets Media or media
Outlets were focusing on the crimes of
bash all of them they were focusing
exposing him the so then out of nowh
Isis came about then all the outlets or
media Outlets diver focus on Isis was
committing crimes utilize your
brain and Al exposed them and by let
make something clear that's we have to
be just we don't believe every person
join Isis is evil man some they were
deluded they were misguided they went
with the good
intention so we have to be just but gen
speaking I are the followers of not the
followers
of so a man came to he said can I go and
fight is that your parents alive said
yes
said fight for the cause for the sake of
Allah with the meaning that be nice to
them be respectful to them be good to
them another narration a man came
to and ask him said I want to seek your
advice I want to go and fight he said is
your mother right said yes it's a goal
there is Jenna there's another narration
that the Jenna is under the feet of the
mothers thisth is is weak however the
meaning is correct the meaning is
correct one of the muham when his mother
passed away he would start crying and
just crying so one of the student said
why are you crying too much he said one
of the gates of Jenna has been closed
today one of the gates of Jenna has been
closed today look at the of the so my de
is if your mother is alive or your
father is alive then be good to them
take care of them look after them treat
them with respect listen to them spend
some times with them cuz you regret I
lost my father when he was 16
and now I wish I spend some time with
him so you regret it and us will never
appreciate Allah blessings until Allah
takes it away from us so and one of the
ways that what we see in our time by you
going doing Haram join gangs and and
selling drugs you causing your mother
harm you causing your father harm when
you start doing Haram you should take
care of them stick with them and as man
because you this is respect your parents
you're know real man you're a coward may
Allah guide us and guide you so to be a
real man the real man the one who takes
care of his parents the real man the one
who treat his parents with respect the
real man the one who deal with his
parents with love and mercy and
respect and uh Su seeing the rights of
the parents there's a lot of Virtues in
doing so Allah will bless you Allah will
bless your life when you take care of
your parents so we have to and there's
many narration many verse many stories
from the S how they dealt with their
parents so in we surise with this and we
ask Allah subhanahu waala to make us
from those who respect their parents who
show love and mercy to their parents who
take take care of their parents Allah to
have our brothers and sisters in
Philistine especially in and to give
them victory over their enemies cuz what
they're going through no doubt is
hardship and no that oppression against
them but it's a evil terrorist criminals
so make Dua for them don't forget your
brothers and sisters in intine make Dua
for them to Allah give them a victory
over their
[Music]
enemies just to remind myself I will
speaking to about it but maybe another
time my brothers is very hot outside and
a lot of women are wied and dressed or
half naked so we have to fear Allah by
lower our gazes low your gaze the first
time yes if you just look at without
intention then Allah is going to hold
you accountable but look down try your
best to turn away from the Haram and
Allah will give you the blessings of the
sweetness of IM we ask Allah to protect
us and protect our families and our
loved ones